on book TV next Colombian presidential
candidate ingrid betancourt discusses
her political memoir until death do us
part
which details the consequences of
corruption in her native country and the
dangers of combating it a political
maverick since she first ran for
legislative office by handing out
condoms to symbolize her battle against
the so-called disease of corruption the
book explores her long fight against the
establishment for her policies and her
life it's 35 minutes
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
books and books my name is Mitchell
Kaplan and as the owner of the bookstore
I just want to welcome you all and say
how exciting it is to be able to be
presenting ingrid betancourt this
afternoon and I thought I would just
tell you a little bit about the way it's
gonna work this afternoon as you can
tell we have these lights here that we
normally don't have and c-span is
recording this so people across the
country can see it as well
and hear it so to make that go as
smoothly as possible
as you know if you've watched any of the
c-span book TV presentations you know
that what is always so interesting are
the lively question-and-answer period
that goes on and in order for the home
audiences to be able to hear the
questions what we ask is that if you
have a question there is a mic right
here and if you could get to the mic
we'd really appreciate that
there will also possibly be a handheld
mic that can get to you as well but it
doesn't it makes it kind of difficult if
you blurt out a question without going
to a mic for the for the audience those
of you who are finding yourself at Books
& ebooks for the first time you might
not know that we've only been in this
location for about a year after being on
the corner for about 20 years and we
want to invite you afterwards to please
take a wander around the store so you
can have an idea of what we've got here
we do a full schedule of events you can
pick up our newsletter or try to get to
books and books calm and find out about
the other events that we have happening
and I would like to reiterate for those
of the people standing in the back we've
entered the world of modern technology
and we've been able to wire the whole
store so this is the event in this room
you can hear in other parts of the store
if you'd like to sit out in the
courtyard of the cafe area or anywhere
and hear it you'll be able to as well
and again thank you all for coming and
we at books and books want to thank
senator Ingrid Betancourt for taking
time
from her current campaign for President
of Colombia
to celebrate with us the publication of
her new memoir until death do us part
my struggle to reclaim Colombia many of
you might know it's been a best-seller
in France this extraordinary account of
her life presents an intimate portrait
of Colombia's current dangerous cocktail
of rampant governmental corruption drug
trafficking and violence that threatens
not only Colombia but also some of the
countries near its borders senator
Betancourt is a neuro ik figure
endangering not only her own life and
causing the disruption of her family but
she does all of this to confront the
underlying causes which have been
destabilizing her native country most of
you know that she comes from a prominent
political family her father served as a
Minister of Education and as an
ambassador to UNESCO and her mother is a
nationally renowned advocate for the
homeless and abandoned children and
she's here with us as well and I'd like
to welcome her
until death do us part focuses on ingrid
betancourt journey from a happily
married woman living in paris to a
political activist negotiating her way
through the maze of Colombia's politics
her story is breathtaking
her story is ennobling and we are
honored to have her with us at books and
books this afternoon and I hope you'll
please give a warm welcome to senator
Ingrid Betancourt
well I would like first to thank you all
for being here with me I would like also
to thank Mitch goblin and books and
books for the opportunity of talking to
you today and also echo my publishers
and help her which has given his support
to what I have done and to my book this
book has a story by its own it was very
difficult for me to make it alive and
and make it published in my country in
my homeland in Colombia when I brought
it I wanted of course first to be
published in Colombia but the doors were
closed and they just tell me that my
story wouldn't interest anybody then I
have this incredible luck to find a man
in France a publisher in France
his name is Ben Affleck so and he
believed in me and he wanted to publish
this book and so he did and it was a
very big surprise for me to see that
this book that was entitled for
Colombians it's a very personal and
intimate story that talks about
Colombians for Colombians to Colombians
well it was a very great success in
France and this was magical because
because it was this big success in
France then in Colombia they had to open
the doors and let the book being
published in Colombia but again it was
difficult it was difficult because
people in Colombia gave me really a hard
time the first thing they did was to
tell Colombians that the book
was a book against my country and I
thought this was very unfair but as the
book at that time wasn't published in my
language I wasn't able to explain that
this was aligned and it was not true so
I had to wait and then I have this also
incredible luck to see that an Italian
publisher just said I'm okay to go if an
even if it's going to be hard and it was
hard it was hard because in France the
book was sued by presidents embarr we
had a trial we went to trial president's
son Perry was saying that the book had
to be prohibited and that it was a lie
and that I was just in a defamation
campaign against him he loves the case
and here I was in Colombia trying to
explain to Colombians what I was trying
to tell to them and tell to the world
tell to the world that in Colombia we
are an incredible country with
incredible people hearted people giving
people loving people but just victims of
us powers I could say perhaps of an
establishment that hasn't had the heart
of the vision to understand that things
have to change that those privileges
that we have in Colombia part of our
society must be sought in another way
that we have to give that we have to to
be able to have a true democracy where
elections won't be a fraud where the
cartels and the drug dealers won't be
able to buy the elections in order to
get their friends into office because of
course this is ruining our chances of a
country to progress we don't have you
seen Colombia we don't have a true
justice or justice just keeps impunity
to those
have power to those who have money and
in particular to those who have friends
in the political field and those are of
course people many times from the drug
cartels we don't have a Congress that
works this I can tell because I was in
Congress for many years in Colombia it
doesn't work because the elections are
referred to the people that are elected
with some except exceptions are people
that are there because they bought the
vote or because they paid bribes to
officials that were counting the votes
so we don't have all people being
represented in in in the Congress in
Colombia we have people doing business
representing themselves trying to see
how with that power the political power
that they gain in Congress they will get
richer illegally and they will protect
their friends are the ones who financed
them and we're talking again about the
drug cartels and then the government
doesn't work also because well to put
the system to work and you have to pass
bills as a government and to pass those
bills you need people to vote in favor
of your projects but then if there is
nobody really wanting to work for the
country but for their own interest and
to enrich legally themselves what they
will ask they won't ask for ideas and
for programs they will ask for money and
for contracts and they will ask to
appoint their friends in strategic
places in our public administration in
order to have power in order to have the
ability of controlling the budget and
just to get hold of that budget so you
see with this system we don't have it
justice we don't have a Congress and
Reid
a government and this is what I need to
say to Colombians because sometimes we
Colombians don't have the whole picture
but when I was trying to tell these two
Colombians and I wanted to wrote that
book
well I was confronted to the system
there are many people in Colombia didn't
want Colombians to understand what was
happening so when we decided finally
with this Italian publisher on the lorry
we helping Colombia to publish this
thing book we had to face many things
the first thing we had to face was where
its threats from the Cali cartel they
went to see the publisher and they told
him that he had to be very careful that
perhaps the book would be published once
in Colombia but that would be all
because they would make sure that the
pub the book wouldn't sell in Colombia
anymore then we had to face the threats
of the lawyers of presidents and where
they had lost the case in France but
they wanted to prevent the book to for
being published in Colombia so they went
to see the publisher and they said that
they were going to sue the program that
the book would have problems and that it
was a very big deal to publish this book
in Colombia after all my publisher stand
by me and so we did publish the book but
the incredible thing you see is that
when finally we have the book printed
and it was available in the bookstores
we had people officials from an
institution that is called the in the
investigative technical Corp of the
prosecutor's office something like that
and they would come to the managers of
the bookstore and they will tell them
you cannot sell that book and you cannot
put that book in the window because this
is an illegal book so people were very
frightened they thought that they might
have problems with the law so they just
took the book out of the store and we
had again to send no use to explain to
the managers of the bookstores that
there was no problem
the incredible thing of this is that I
have been all over the world talking
about this book it has been like a key
for opening doors and explaining all
over the world were what we are
suffering and are struggling Colombia
what we want to do and we want to
achieve and our dreams as Colombians to
just get rid of that regime very corrupt
regime to be able to leave as you leave
your American to you as European live in
order to have a right protected in order
to have two elections in order to have a
normal democracy but I didn't have the
support of the press in Colombia I have
had this report all over the world of
the press the international press but
now not the press of my country no not
lying about this book I mean Clemente
couldn't know that the book was
available for them this was incredible I
have been able to speak about this book
everywhere but not in my country in
despite of all this the book in Colombia
has been a great success it is firming I
don't know how but it's selling and now
it comes to you
and now it comes to you and I really
want you to know that by reading this
book you're just helping me a lot
you are helping me to make the world
understand what Columbia is all about
Columbia is a great country that needs
help it need help not only financial
help but it needs help to recover our
democracy we need people to understand
that more than money we need people to
come to our country time from you from
you journalists from your politicians
from your Senators and Representatives
in order to come to our country and just
witness what we are going through just
be part of it because if there are eyes
in Columbia thing and telling the world
what is happening then I think I truly
believe that it will be very difficult
for this corrupt system to just go on
and on and on and it will have to stop
and then you will have contributed to
this endeavor more thank you very much
we will have some time for questions so
if there is a question as I say there's
a mic over here so if someone would like
to go to the mic and ask a question I
would be great I think
good afternoon I said well it's okay the
question I have is related more towards
your political side and let me first
commend you on your piece of work I
think it took great courage and
determination to actually put together
such a literary piece and it's related
towards what plans do you have or may
have for what can you do to encourage
the current Colombian government to help
seek funding proper funding to allow the
thousands and thousands of Colombia that
live outside of Colombia that have dual
citizenship and can actually participate
by voting what what can you do or what
would you be willing to do to help
create
sir I can explain to you something it's
a c-span's mic it's not the mic bookshop
so the question yes well as you can see
we have a pretty vocal crowd but in a
nutshell what can you do or what will
you do to help ensure that Colombians
can actively participate in the United
States for example and have proper
places of voting for they can actually
go ahead and vote and make a difference
in Colombia this is very important when
I was senator I worked ok the question
is what can I do in order to enhance the
participation of the Colombians that are
living abroad outside Colombia in order
to give them the opportunity of
participating political issues in
Colombia and vote for calm when I was in
the Senate I worked in a in a law in a
bill that would give us the opportunity
of having a representor from outside the
country a Colombian living outside the
country abroad that would be liked it by
the people living outside the country we
had many problems in passing this bill I
would think that the reason this didn't
go through was because in in in my
country the traditional political class
fears fused votes that would come
without being controlled by what we call
the Machine area which is the
possibility of buying the votes and
controlling them in order to favor one
particular candidates so I don't know
what we'll do the other candidates that
are running for presidency I can assure
you that the president Pastrana didn't
really gave too much importance to the
issue but for me it's important it's
important because I know that here in
the United States Colombians living here
and Colombians living in other parts of
the world have and this could seem weird
but it's the reality have perhaps more
information about what is happening in
Colombia that many times we do in
Colombia because you have access to
other kind of medias and you are more
informed that sometimes we can be in
Colombia so for me I know that here
there is a opinion it votes a free vote
and this is I think one of the powers
that will change my country here are the
people that won't want the change to the
new Colombia that we want to be you you
really have put a lot of emphasis in
corruption as a cuban-american I am NOT
impressed if this is what the book
speaks about only do you touch on the
very very difficult political struggle
of your country or 40 years of
guerrillas X percentage of the territory
met in the hands of those gorillas a
third force of the right and the
government which is very difficult to
really put a process of peace
what do you touch I'll read the book in
the book about the Korea problem the
paramilitaries problem and the war
situation canonical yes and the drug
what I would like just to point out is
that in Colombia violence is financed by
drug trafficking guerillas are financed
by drugs paramilitaries are financed by
drugs political class and corrupt
political crisis financed by drugs and
this leads to terrorism the war that
we're facing in Colombia is not a
traditional war we don't have armies and
troops fighting each other we have
troops that will kill women children
that will burn villages in order to
achieve political goals and to rise in
their military advantages so it is
impossible to talk about corruption
without talking about guerrillas and
paramilitary you're aware oh yes because
I know that your mother was involved in
supporting a political candidate for
presidency who was brutally killed the
are you concerned about that issue of
your personal security the issue that is
brought here is the issue of of security
there are candidates that have been
killed in Colombia previously and what
what is my concern I think that we all
commence live with this idea in our mind
we know that this is a possibility we
know that people a lot of people have
been killed
especially when they begin to talk about
things that normally must not be
revealed and yes this is a concern I can
tell you that because of that concern I
have been forced to take decisions that
have been very hard on me that had hurt
me a lot I have had to send my children
away from Colombia
I sent them with when they were ten and
seven now there are teenagers
there are 16 and 13 so I have missed
their childhood
we are concerned but fear cannot be what
moves us there are other things more
important than death good afternoon I'm
all Colombian American as well and I I
read with your book your book with great
interest and command you with the
courage that you have display is amazing
particularly knowing how things operate
over there my question to you is given
that you've been fighting this struggle
for over 10 years what type of support
have you gather with the people I mean
is your message getting through and and
and how do you feel the Colombian people
are reacting to it ok the Colombian
people are reacting to my struggle and
my message I wouldn't be here if I
hadn't had the support of my people the
first time I was elected I was an
anonymous person nobody knew me I did a
quite scandalous campaign I distributed
condoms in the streets and I and I was
telling and this in a very conservative
country like Colombia I was telling
people we have to face AIDS and when we
have to struggle and protect ourselves
against 8 we will use a condom now we
have another struggle we have to protect
our society from another disease which
is corruption and we need to be
protected and the protection is to vote
for someone honest and so I would give
them the condom and I would tell them I
hope you will remember me in the next
elections
and so they did then I was I went for
for the Senate and very surprisingly
because nobody was expecting this I was
elected with the highest score in my
country I obtained the most big amount
of votes in that election so these
perhaps answers that question thank you
as well we are very aware of the
situation that is been taking place in
the Congress in the Senate for so many
years with the corrupt infrastructure
that is developed and will you be able
to you to bring to justice people like
mr. Sun pare we are not much fun off who
have caused this situation over the past
years and I also believe that it needs
to be a change in the Constitution where
perhaps if we are able to clean the
house it will not only be in four years
it will take longer than that so if we
have somebody who we can support that it
hopefully be in the house for former or
for more than four years that will be a
great the question is are we going to be
able to bring presidents and prayer to
justice and how are we going to do to
really clean the system because it will
take more than four years to do so I
will I will really work on the rebirth
of our institutions I think this is the
way we have to go in order not only to
recover democracy but also to be able to
win the battle and the war on drugs if
we want to do so the first thing I will
do is to clean the Congress so we will
have new elections so those elections
will have to have observers
international observers we will need to
be very keen in regard in observing and
being sure that the software that is
being used to tell the votes will not be
manipulated which it is in this precise
moment and we will have to clean the
electoral system if we have a clean
election I can assure you that we will
have good people coming into Congress if
this happens we will do two major things
first we will reform
judicial system and by doing this who
will be able to guarantee that some pair
as president as former president or
whoever
despite of all art their titles their
importance
the wealthiness whatever if they had
broke the law they must be in prison
famous go to trial and that must be
Church and they must pay for what they
have done I think this is the best
example we can give to our people in
order to recover our print our
principles and our values so cannot tell
me I really want to do this what do you
what do you think about the person
crisis of the peace negotiation ok the
present crisis of the peace negotiation
I think we were expecting it I think the
crisis began from the first day we began
negotiations because we had a government
that was kneeling to the guerrillas I
want to tell you that I really do
believe that the only way the only path
to peace in Colombia is through
negotiations I don't believe in war I
don't believe in confrontation I believe
that we need to reconcile the family of
Colombia but we need to be strong in
that negotiation we cannot be weak
because if the government is weak we're
just losing the opportunities of
bringing the guerrillas to a negotiation
where they will surrender arms but they
will gain they will they will recover
they will help us recover our democracy
and then we will be able to fight for
power but with ideas and with programs
and not with weapons and not with
killings
now the guerrilla must today tell us as
Colombians who they are are they
revolutionaries are they willing to do
sound and deep reforms to our system do
they want to be partners in that
peaceful revolution or are they only
drug dealers and terrorists and this is
what we will find out I have a lot of
Colombian friends and I know so many
people come here and they stay here and
their you know their kids are born here
and so on
what can Colombians do because there's a
lot of Colombians that have businesses
they have money they have education and
Colombia is a great country have a lot
of educated people - all these people
want to do something but what about the
people here what can they do to like
speed up that progress what can they do
to make Colombian better there must be
something wrong in the in the in the
sense that there's got there has to be
people in Colombia they're very upset
someone needs to help them and maybe you
should come from here I don't know what
do you think yes I really believe that
we have to be to make a network of
solidarity from Colombians abroad and
Colombians in Colombia there are many
things we can work on the first thing is
to vote you can vote
I mean Colombians that are here that
have a double nationality that they have
an American passport but have a
Colombian passport they can vote in the
continent for the next nation elections
there are many Colombians that have been
coming here and that haven't legalized
their situation and this prevents them
to vote and it's it's it's a pity
because they should I mean I really
believe that democracy is our weapon to
recover our country but there are other
things that they're wealthy people here
Colombians that have done well here and
I always have dreamed that we should
have a network of information from the
United States to Colombia perhaps a
newspaper
perhaps a television station something
that would give us as Colombians the
right to have
the total and true information you see
in Colombian the media's are controlled
by their owners and those owners well
they have the right to do so but they
are just transmitting the information
only regarding their own interests so we
don't get all the information there are
many scandals that are covered in
Colombia there are many people that
should be questioned in many of the
attitudes that the the the things that
they have done and our press just
doesn't say anything so you know I I
really believe that democracy and
information goes together free press is
important for democracy we have free
press in Colombia there is no government
governmental censor but there is an
private sensor which is that if you
don't say as a journalist what the owner
of the media wants to hear well you lose
your you'll lose your job so I would
really like to see something like this
happening really media is coming to
Colombia and I say this because there
are some people some wealthy people that
in Colombia that can afford to buy the
direct if you think the cable TV and so
they will have the information coming
from outside but normally Colombians
just have the information that they can
have in the normal television in
Colombia and they won't they won't be
properly informed we can take one more
question based on core this is not
exactly a question but what I have to
say is that unless there's a an
intervention by the United States
I don't think Colombia will be saved in
the next 100 years well our friend here
is saying that he
believe that unless there is an
intervention from the American
government Columbia won't be safe I
don't believe in that I really I really
believe that we need to clean the system
we need to clean the system we need to
make sure that our democracy will will
work and I need also to say that it's
important to have the Americans helping
us the American government and the
people of America for example in this
peace process it's very important to
have the international community helping
us but I want to see that help in
political issues in helping us doing the
reforms we need to do the political
reform the agrarian reform the economic
reform not to help us just kill
ourselves I don't believe in war I'm
sorry I don't believe in war I don't
believe in war inside a country I can
understand that you can sometimes you
need to fight other countries but when
it is between brothers and sisters the
only thing that you can do is to
reconciliate and to have political
outcomes in order to solve your problems
look what happened to the IRA one
century fighting and then at the end
after killing bumping kidnapping they
have to come and sit at the table and
negotiate I don't want to lose this
opportunity I know that if today we
don't negotiate in 30 years we will be
forced to negotiate that we have lost 30
years and my children won't be able to
see the Columbia I want to give them a
Calabria free of drugs a club v drugs v
corruption fifth film violence and in
this we are all together in the same
struggle
Ingrid Betancourt a member of the Green
Party has been both a congresswoman and
a senator in the government of Colombia
she's currently running for president
her memoir until death do us part my
struggled to reclaim Colombia as
published by Eko press an imprint of
HarperCollins for more information you
can visit their website
HarperCollins dot-com